you can ask me about my throat tattoo
it says anguish you know what anguish
means right
what does it mean extreme mental hurt
pain and suffering to the body and mind
yeah ask me about that i think you just
did
you just told me you've been through a
lot of anguish
yeah tell me about it okay
well the whole anguish on my throat it's
for my daddy you know my daddy he hung
himself through opiate withdrawals
he was paralyzed from the waist down
doctor ended up cutting his spinal cord
and paralyzing him from the waist down
well the man was paralyzed before the
overdose uh
my daddy hung his self from opiate
withdrawals
from detoxing from quitting doing
opiates
he couldn't take the pain and he killed
himself okay so
he was paralyzed before that he was
paralyzed before that he got paralyzed
in a really young age
working for the army corps of
engineering building locks and dams
he fell off the dam and it paralyzed him
all right well they done back surgery
and they cut his spinal cord
and it severed his spinal cord and
paralyzed him
through recovery because he could still
walk but his spinal cord was messed up
all right well he ended up hanging
himself through the opiate withdrawals
and that's why i got the anguish across
my throat
because after my daddy killed himself
i've been struggling with opiate
withdrawals my whole life and
hell i don't want to end up like my
daddy you know
and after he killed himself man i
i wanted to kill myself so bad because
of the
bull crap that i've done to my daddy i
have tortured my daddy
throughout my life i've been abused by
my brother my brother was older
and hell him being six three 320 pounds
he's a big old boy
big old country [ __ ] he's beat the
hell out of me my whole life uh are we
allowed to cuss
yes you are okay well he's beat the hell
on him in my whole life hell he's
shot me in my leg he's flipped a f-150
on top of me
hell i ain't got no spleen appendix
gallbladder full foot of my large
intestine
for my small intestine he tried killing
me when i was 15.
flipped the truck on top of me it
crushed me
uh and that's how i got addicted to
opiates so you grew up in alabama i grew
up in alabama what city
uh bessemer best friend alabama and then
i moved to a rep
a rebs just a bunch of country [ __ ]
you know uh i loved it out there um
but you know the
watching my daddy with the opiates me
and my daddy we
started shooting heroin together when i
was uh
about 17 years old me and my dad started
shooting heroin together
and hell my dad told me one day he said
hey son he says
uh i gave you the gift that never
stopped giving i gave you a hep c
i was like what yeah and so
i found out i got hep c from using
needle after my own father
yeah that's some bull crap but um
how was you 32 32
32. um
when did you start using uh opiates yeah
i started opiates when i was 15 years
old
the doctors gave me liquid morphine
and i've been an iv user ever since and
you lost your dad at what age
um i lost my daddy at 23
he hung himself i just got out in prison
i ain't been out of prison for 30 days
my daddy hung himself
and i felt like it was partially my
fault cause
i'm right there beside him begging him
for his pills and he's
handing me his pills and there he is
going through withdrawals
next thing you know
he killed himself hell i
i really feel like that's partially my
fault i shouldn't have been eating these
pills
well i wasn't eating them i was shooting
them you know
but um he'd give me anything he had
his last dollar it didn't matter how he
come down to his last pain pill he'd
split it in half and give me half of it
you know that man give me anything um
you're close to your dad yeah real close
more than your brother yes yes um
my brother just finally recently got
close
um after daddy killed himself
we started getting closer um
a lot of my family members accused me
hanging my daddy
i couldn't do that it's impossible
i love my daddy and uh some of my family
members even quit talking to me
because they thought i was partially
reason
my daddy killed herself um
lost my mama four days after my birthday
um january 25th
my mama uh passed away cirrhosis to the
liver
at blount county jail that denied her
medical attention
she swole up in a drunk tank and died
you know um yeah
um it's a rough childhood
yeah um how far did you go to school
seventh grade quit in seventh
i had to take care of my paralyzed
father
you know having to help him in and out
of the bathtub
um how my brother was in prison
so there was nobody but me
who introduced you to heroin as a
teenager
myself myself for real um
the doctors introduced me to opiates
stealing the tails
sir you were taking your dad's pills
stealing them
i would steal them if he wouldn't give
them to me
you know if he wouldn't give them to me
i'd take them
i'd take them even if it didn't matter
how it was
i'd hope holler throw [ __ ]
biggest piece of [ __ ] you ever met you
know
feel like that um
i got a lot of pain because what i done
you know eats me up inside
really does how much prison time have
you done
well uh i've been
in and out of incarceration my whole
life you know
um for what kind of stuff um from
theft charges to drug charges to
you name it um first time i went to
prison was
actually to keep my brother from going
back
my brother was um he was actually
17 years old dating a 15 year old girl
he turned 18 years old and she was still
15. and the man who had custody of her
my brother ended up beating the hell out
of him
and he pressed charges for statutory
rape and kidnapping because
him and his old lady ran away together
and so they locked my brother up
gave him 215 split threes run wild
so he ended up doing six years in prison
he gets out
and steals this man's four-wheeler
correction officer spoiler
so i go up to cullman county jail and
sign an affidavit in a statement saying
i'm the one who stole it
they reinstated my brother's parole and
sent me to prison for my first time
that was to keep my brother from going
back for 24 years
and uh i did that and
held my brother's been right ever since
ever since i
he quit stealing he's doing good got a
baby
how many years did you do me i'd done
three years
first time
second time i'd done 14 months i've done
another 14 months
um i've been to
kilby bullock and elmore i've been
to numerous county jails
um yeah
prison's not really a place anybody
wants to go especially if you're white
not in alabama not nowhere for real
um
see my daddy being paralyzed from waist
down
raising you know two boys on
disability wasn't enough money
especially one of them being a
full-blown drug addict
the other one just always being hungry
well my daddy had his first massive
heart attack
shoveling asphalt on walker you know
you ever seen a paraplegic on a walker
no you see him in a wheelchair my
daddy's the only person i've ever seen
my whole entire life
be paralyzed from the waist down
couldn't wiggle his toes or nothing but
wouldn't get in a wheelchair
he'd drag himself around on walker
you know of the uh one of the most
i look back and i laugh at this because
man
first time i ever got my ass [ __ ] by
old crippled man
look um i've been strung out been up for
about 24 days
on meth good anhydrous
yeah uh like red dope look
um i'm sitting here telling my daddy i
said man i need some money for
some heroin he didn't want to give it to
me and i
start throwing a fit he looks at me i'm
18 years old i'm 98 pounds
he looks at me and says son you look
like you need a jar of [ __ ] peanut
butter and throws it
i grab it and i throw it and sling it
through the winch
the window of the house busts the window
of the house out right next to him
and he's in his rocking chair and
hell being 240 pounds paralyzed from the
waist down
you know walking on a walker he's swole
he's got some big ol arms boys rocking
in that chair
and they say i know i'm sitting there
cussing and mumbling
and he launches himself up on that chair
and he's on his fist like a gorilla and
he's boom boom boom and he grabs me by
my leg and snatches me to the ground
climbs on top of me and just beats the
hell out of me
i'm talking about black eye busted lee
up
man that old man beat the hell out of me
and i i sit back and i
i love i i love that i love
thinking about that because i deserved
it you know
i wish he'd got me like that for every
time i ever done him wrong
you know but there's a lot of times he
didn't
hell he bought me um a porsche 924
i sold it for a hundred dollars cash
just pissed me off
uh yeah i had nice things
destroyed them sold them for dope it
didn't matter
how he bought me a record and what'd i
do with it go out and steal cars
you know support my heroin
addiction i loved it i still love it
i can't even find no good heroin down
here in cat well in california you can't
even find me
here [ __ ] about six six seven months
yeah but brought you up to california um
that's really something i don't even
want to talk about
that's yeah
yeah some things
yeah i don't need to talk about i ain't
trying to
burn myself up man um
i came to california hoping to get away
from the heroin but
the heroin was no good down here and uh
hell i just switched to fentanyl i
thought i was going to
get out here get me a job and do right i
got a job
but hell i ain't worth the [ __ ]
ten dollars an hour minimum wage 15.
you can't even get off the streets with
that
not down here you're staying in a tent
or i live in a tent living tent
constantly getting my [ __ ] stolen
how i get so high man i nod out people
hell they took my key to my bike
off of my lantern around my neck i'm so
[ __ ] up
stole my bike stole my backpack my
phone's in it
cash everything i was high and i'm
sitting there looking at the dude
didn't even know what was [ __ ] going
on
robin [ __ ] on me
i love it down here do you have kids no
i don't have no kids thank god they
wouldn't need to live a
lifestyle i do
i love stealing [ __ ] my mama got me
addicted to stealing [ __ ] when i was
young
first time i ever got in trouble for
stealing anything i was eight years old
me and my brother um there's this place
in birmingham called unclaimed baggage
and my mama she took us out there to
steal [ __ ]
with a tandem dump truck and then my
brother filled it slat full of stolen
goods
and the reason we got caught was uh she
got drunk passed down on the horn
of the dump truck hell they came out
there and
found 160 000 and counterfeit cash
and all kind of stolen [ __ ] we didn't
fill the whole dump truck up
they locked me gary and mama up i was
eight gary was 12.
i don't know how old mom was um
you know and she had us stealing at a
very young age
riding around in a buggy pulling
stickers off [ __ ] slapping
slapping different price tags on at four
she started us
out young how are you supporting
yourself now on schedule
um i got a job
making ten dollars an hour i go to work
when i want to
um i do mechanic work
i fix electric bikes and [ __ ] like that
you know everybody down here likes bikes
and [ __ ] how i
pretty much fix anything you got
you know being raised in alabama that's
all you want to do is build hot rods and
[ __ ] and run them up and down the roads
what do you think of california alabama
i think everybody thinks i'm racist
i think they think i'm a hell hitler
type because
the way i talk i'll be walking down the
road and they'll
be going ah you got black folk in
alabama
i know but hell they caught like me
hell they don't even like black folks
down there in alabama right
i'm dead serious black folks don't even
like black folks
i don't know why that is do you have
friends out here do i have friends
uh not very many i don't like talking to
people
not really i like to stay myself friends
they just want your drugs
so especially here huh especially down
here yeah
so if you got any friends all they're
wanting to do is
do dope so you're better off by yourself
what do you worry about what do i worry
about
um
getting bammed up going to prison
that's what i worry about i don't worry
about nothing else besides going to
prison or
losing my brother
you know my brother's all i got my
sister my sister
she's always been with granny so
she ain't never lived that lifestyle so
you know do you think being around your
mom and dad
is what led you here oh yeah most
definitely
my uh my mama being a drunk my daddy
being an opiate addict
hell mama i was a fetal alcohol syndrome
baby because my mama drank through
the whole pregnancy you know
well i was prone to addiction before i
was born is what they said
what are your best memories best
memories
hell i still remember taking a bath in
the sink man
i was that small i still remember that
because that was one of the good
memories
mama sitting there bathing man dog
knocks over the china cabinet and glass
goes everywhere and i just start
laughing i don't know why i'm laughing
over the dog
knocking over the china cab now it's
just baby
but i still remember that
yeah i don't know i always
just
good memories
good memories do you see uh yeah
you have hope of getting out off of
fentanyl
no i don't ever see me quit using
no i see me dying to addiction
do you think you're more likely to die
than get clean yeah
yeah i know for a fact um
i'll never i'll
the only way i would ever come off
of an oak off opiates is
if the doctors would write me opiates
and that's just me
doing it legally that's all
that's the only way what about suboxone
methodology
no methadone i
i like methadone hell it takes 200
milligrams
to get me [ __ ] up so no i don't need
that
um
no no i don't see me coming off fentanyl
heroin nothing like that i see me
hell i've done a shot while i was
waiting on you to get out your car
just to be honest with you how i can hit
myself so fast it's not funny
you're probably or your body's built up
a tolerance of
fentanyl you probably can't kill
yourself i get i can shoot i shot over a
gram and a half of fentanyl in
probably six hours that kill a horse
yeah most people's like oh my god man
hell i'm
slamming half grams people ain't here's
dying off a point
like what the hell you know i can't even
get high off this [ __ ]
you know saying it's the best fetty
around it's purple it's pink it's yellow
it's green
that was trash to me [ __ ] in alabama we
got this [ __ ] fire our
[ __ ] heroine's [ __ ] better than the
best fitty y'all got down here
be honest yeah
what's what's the most important thing
you've learned in your life most
important thing
don't trust nobody for real
hey
well
you can trust family sometimes to an
extent
how my brother he ain't never want me to
do nothing but get clean he ain't never
done nothing
hell he's made my bond so many times
it's unreal
hell uh he came off my bond just because
i wanted to go get some [ __ ] one time
he didn't want me [ __ ] with his dope
[ __ ]
huh came off my bottom put my ass right
back in jail because i wouldn't listen
i miss my brother
i miss my brother bad
yeah all right man well thank you so
much for telling me your story
yeah uh yeah i need to go to work
actually i'm
late oh [ __ ] sorry